[Musica]
stiamo per atterrare allacciare le
cinture di sicurezza quante volte vi
sarà capitato ed è l'unica volta in cui
si ha la possibilità di vedere dall'alto
la più incredibile la più potente la più
diffusa invenzione dell'uomo la città ed
è anche l'unica volta in cui sicuramente
vi è capitato di pensare ma com'è
possibile che milioni di persone da
migliaia di anni
cerchino questi luoghi per stare insieme
si ammassino scelgono di vivere non
tutti separati ma insieme in quella che
chiamiamo città e vi sarà anche passato
per la testa
una domanda importante ma è positivo o
negativo tutto questo ma sarebbe meglio
potenziare questo fenomeno o limitarlo
questa è una storia che va indietro nel
tempo in realtà questa è manchester nel
1845 era la più grande città e più
popolosa dell'occidente come vedete
forse non era granché e di fatto in
questa città
cominciò quello che io chiamo il più
lungo processo della storia con la
sentenza più inaspettata
e il processo è ovviamente il processo
alle città e lo iniziarono questi due
ragazzi poi diventati abbastanza famosi
karl marx e il suo amico engel
passeggiavano per manchester e non
vedevano quello che oggi vi capita
quando fate il vostro weekend a new york
oa parigi
immaginate vedevano strade strette senza
fogne povertà dappertutto inquinamento
ma non quello di oggi il vero smog che
faceva sì che delle particelle di
carbone impedivano la vista anche uno
con l'altro
e ovviamente i due scrisse un libro che
si chiamava la condizione della classe
operaia nelle città in cui accusavano la
città di tutti i mali del mondo era la
città ad essere causa dell'inquinamento
della insicurezza della povertà e non
c'era altro modo che limitare questo
fenomeno al possibile era come dire un
atteggiamento malsano una cosa
necessaria volte ma da contenere
e da questo nel corso degli anni siamo
dal 1850 all'inizio del novecento
nacquero anche delle discipline degli
strumenti per limitare questo fenomeno
dato che era probabilmente la causa di
tutti i polmoni i problemi del mondo
nacquero delle scienze l'urbanistica che
vedete qua dietro una cosa tremenda che
forse avete qualche volta conosciuto che
ha degli strumenti bizzarri uno si
chiama regolamento edilizio che quella
roba per cui quando dovete cambiare un
muro in casa dovete fare centinaia di
pratiche e poi la pianificazione il
piano cioè l'idea che ci sia qualcuno
dall'alto che riesce a immaginare il
futuro di una città nei prossimi 50 anni
solo lui è solo nella sua testa o ancora
e per ultima la zonizzazione che
fortunatamente non avete conosciuto
tutti ma che riesce addirittura a dire
e a pretendere di immaginare in un
centimetro della città
cosa deve accadere nel futuro qui una
casa qui un ufficio qui un teatro e poi
immaginiamo anche i film la cultura che
si espone molto contro le città è famoso
un film o una serie di film negli anni
ottanta fuga da new york fuga da los
angeles dove manhattan è diventata un
isola incontrollabile una città piena di
violenza e di terrore tanto da
abbandonare la e forse perché ha visto
il film vi ricordate diventa un carcere
dove tutti i cattivi del mondo vengono
lanciati dall alto e che si scannino per
sempre la cosa interessante di questo
processo è che come tutti i processi
questo forse anche per l'italia un po
lunghino dal 1845 a una ventina d'anni
fa arriva la sentenza e caso unico nella
scienza
tale sentenza è una sentenza di totale
assoluzione non solo leggendo le
motivazioni di questa sentenza si scopre
che la città non è la causa di tutti i
pon il mondo ma stante la crescita della
popolazione
essa è la soluzione a tutte le grandi
questioni
qui si affaccia il genere umano la
demografia l'inquinamento la
sostenibilità ambientale la sicurezza e
lo sviluppo economico la creazione di
lavoro la capacità di creare conoscenza
e di fatto questa sentenza elenca anche
tre importanti elementi che motivano
questa capacità che la città di
migliorare il mondo la prima è la
densità vedete qua le mie spalle una mia
foto fatta dall'alto della mia città
e la densità cioè quante più persone
quante più attività quante più
immaginazioni riescono a stare in uno
stesso metro quadro
tanto più questo effetto positivo si
verifica e la seconda è la diversità
cioè il fatto che non solo ci siano
tante cose in un posto piccolo ma che
tali cose siano diverse che ci siano
poveri ricchi persone di tutti i paesi
del mondo persone che amano il calcio
altri che come me ignorano anche il nome
del più famoso calciatore e il terzo
elemento è la creatività
questa è una bizzarra notte bianca dove
migliaia di persone per una sera porta
un tavolino una sedia da casa il cibo e
si riuniscono e mangiano insieme in una
piazza la creatività e questa capacità
di immaginare nelle città allora ecco la
mia idea che la città alla fine assolta
e in qualche modo additata come
soluzione è in realtà un meccanismo la
definizione di città non è più la
grandezza gli abitanti siamo tutti
abituati a confrontare questo o
quell'altro città per gli abitanti per
la grandezza per il pil prodotto no
la città un meccanismo la città funzione
risolve le grandi questioni dell'umanità
perché come una scatola nera un grande
meccanismo che trasforma interessi
diversi
tanti individui che provengono da storie
da regioni che hanno obiettivi diversi
che se costretti a fare un viaggio
insieme in un auto litigherebbero tutto
il giorno invece la città riesce a
trasferire magicamente costantemente
tali interessi individuali in benessere
collettivo e quindi la definizione di
città non è più una definizione statica
la città salva al mondo in quanto
costantemente riesce a generare questo
meccanismo di trasformazione positiva e
quindi è una città può anche perdere il
suo status
adesso sappiamo tutti alcune città anche
in italia anche grandi
che forse in questo momento dopo
millenni di storia hanno sospeso
temporaneamente questa capacità o altre
magari neglette magari mai considerate
che invece in questo momento o per certi
periodi riescono ad essere questo
meccanismo virtuoso e allora non
dobbiamo avere paura della città
dobbiamo passare da meccanismi e
strumenti di contenimento del fenomeno
urbano a meccanismi e strumenti che ne
accelerano lo sviluppo e vi farò due
esempi del lavoro che sto conducendo in
questi ultimi anni e che non hanno paura
del fenomeno urbano ma che cercano di
alimentare questo meccanismo sparandola
grossa come utopia e coraggio
il primo esempio è di milano e questo è
un'immagine dall'altro della città dal
satellite e sono evidenziati alcuni
parchi non tutti ma un insieme di verde
poco conosciuto nel centro della città
dieci minuti li metterò dal duomo che
insieme ed è questa la mia idea ed è
questo anche il viaggio che ho fatto per
anni con questa mappa in giro per la
città l'idea è di nominare questo
insieme di verde con coraggio perché si
crede nella città come il palco urbano
più grande del mondo 72 km di verde un
palco orbitale che ogni giorno si può
percorrere come ho fatto è che andando
ad esempio a vedere le mappe della città
si può immaginare come elemento di
diversità e di forza credendo nelle cose
positive dei sistemi in cui viviamo non
lasciandoci diciamo distruggere dalla
retorica del traffico la retorica ancora
novecentesca prima della sentenza di
assoluzione delle città come nemici
da repellere il cemento non so se avete
tutti in mente queste retoriche e il
secondo esempio è invece quello di una
città a qualche migliaio di km da qui ci
ho lavorato si chiama buonos aires in
argentina e la capitale e si poneva un
quesito qualche anno fa
cosa fare di questa città nel 2030 sono
tutti spaventati buenos aires più che in
altri paesi è il magnete di tutta la
nazione
il luogo dove tutti cercano una
possibilità ma questo meccanismo che è
la definizione di città che vi ho
proposto sera in qualche modo inceppato
violenza povertà anche derivata da una
crisi nazionale più ampia è la
tentazione qual'era come al solito
quella di limitare nello sviluppo e
invece con coraggio sparandola grossa
con la stessa capacità di credere nella
potenza di questa arma mentale quali
sono le città come col palco vitale
anche nel caso di buenos aires ho
proposto tre strategie tre strategie che
accelerano lo sviluppo e che vedete qua
dietro una maggiore densità cioè una
maggiore popolazione una maggiore
infrastrutturazione e la creazione di
spazi pedonali o verdi vedete questa è
la densità il piano dice nel 2030
dobbiamo non limitarci ma aumentare un
milione di abitanti in più nella città
costruire sostituendo quartieri più
bassi con quartieri più densi chiamando
la popolazione non solo dell'argentina
ma del tutto il mondo e i creativi a
riunirsi e poi costruire un sistema di
infrastrutture anche su ferro che
permettono di credere ancora di più in
questo sviluppo e accelerare le poi come
vi dicevo degli spazi di socialità
degli spazi di verde e pedonali e queste
tre strategie insieme scommettevano
sullo sviluppo di buenos aires consci
che le città sono la soluzione a tutti i
poeti del mondo e allora quando ancora
una volta atterrerete e magari
scegliendo il posto sul finestrino
qualche dette dall'alto questa grande
invenzione dell'umanità che è la città
avrete nel cuore un sentimento diverso e
saprete rispondere a quella domanda che
vi siete posti tante volte e forse
sarete orgogliosi di vivere in quello
che io chiamo il secolo delle città
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]